[Music]
the title of Grand Master was first
officially awarded in 1950 now in 2017
at the st. Louis winter Invitational
that tradition continues hello chess fan
welcome to the fifth day and the
penultimate round of the winter
invitational GM and IM norm event there
are only a few players left who can earn
a norm or if you're Joel banawa get that
rating up over 2400 to get the IM title
remember to be with us on tuesday
februari the 21st live at 11am central
at us chess champ calm all right here we
are back in the IM norm field and i'm
sitting here with feed a master guardian
car gaara you played two good games your
last to you one and even though you're
out of norm contention let's take a look
at some of those games sure absolutely
so yeah i'm not having the greatest
tournament but i did play a couple good
games i've had a couple of nietzermann
that i missed as well so i guess i'll
only show you my good games so let's
start with the first one I played
against international master Annie mirth
of the very strong player now there's a
really interesting sequence that could
happen and it starts with 94 I was
hoping that if you play 94 here
attacking my queen now it's you can
pause the video if you'd like so this is
pretty cool move that's going to come up
this is what I was intending it didn't
happen the game though its Queen takes
c6 rook takes c6 real tasty stuff so
sacrificing my queen for two bishops and
then King goes to ephrata which the
otherwise feed in a lot of trouble she
goes tht a ruby stone is already game
over he has faith and now I was
calculating just during the game really
really hard is it really worth it to go
to this position you added a sacrifice
of my queen it's really really risky but
i was thinking of route kha trying to
win the window queen surprisingly it's
really hard to defend for black for
example one variation is
night of six ro ke che check 98 and
Bishop b5 Wow two [ __ ] from the
center is like a queen sometimes right
so right now I have a lot of
compensation root g 6 and now the final
blow is this world coming to a 1 and 2
87 and then some things are going to
happen on basically this is game over
actually so this was really sad but I'll
do a sample line let's say Queenie 8 or
something or just some move he takes me
40 k 7 and already it's over for example
my thread is pretty interesting here my
thread is to go it should be a true g
hate and now this was actually mate
really cool mate right so what does it
didn't happen so anyway so in the game
he took the pawn I play root K 1 another
interesting moment happen at this point
but here I felt like his pieces were
loose I'm putting a lot of pressure on
it Bishop it's night it's other bishop
so I thought hmm is there a way I could
take advantage of this excellent fish a
24 so again you pause the video and see
what my played here so i decided to
stack my rook for the bishop and now i
have complete domination over the dark
squares right and he's actually unable
to defend both the night and the rook
because it doesn't have any pieces left
to defend it so he has to give up one of
these guys he decided here up the rook
and I i took night and then i tracked my
other [ __ ] show and I got back more
than more than I gave up and I was able
to win the game from here that was my
first game yeah I dig how you channel
Jonathan schrantz there and give the
people a chance to yeah treat it as a
puzzle that's very cool but I have a
coach so I sometimes I do lose ok can we
go to the next game yes absolutely take
it to the next game ok so the next game
hope I loaded it but yep it was the game
stuff looks like today actually against
p.m. at Scherger bin ski at the mood
that he should have played what's fish
about six
however now I calculated that I'm not
entirely sure it's completely completely
winning but I have a really strong
attack after letting Bishop II 486 and
now clean f5 it's a super strong attack
may be here computer like to sacrifice
the brook for more material and get like
a bunch of pawns this is the crazy
variation that is yeah it's really close
to crazy how I i want to sleep up all
the pawns on the king said but there's a
better move here that I thought actually
it was 86 i believe it was sorry it was
after Bishop of 6 clean up clean up five
or bishop yeah queen of five and then g4
it was strong this is also strong i
believe so one of these moves should be
should be good for white or per tipping
Ferengi for anyway the movie played was
g6 i took upon and now I was expecting
me to play Bishop f8 clearing the way
for the Queen and I had a really nice
response for this it was Bishop d5
threatening may 98 the only way to
defend was Queen g7 and I had a really
important for single here it was Queen
e6 attacking to work on CH because none
of the roof moves I have another forcing
move threatening made on g8 and he would
have to lose his Queen and then my queen
and bishops was so powerful I'm going to
get more material after that so Queen
again the attacking that undefended rook
those basic tactics coming together
right and so but he played bishop to d8
which was a weird movie because it kind
of disconnect so the look from eight and
now I have subtle ways to win here I
just shows the most simple way I just
threaten mate on g8 and if he can't stop
it unless you have to go for Bishop this
means i'll be up three pawns so he
played super sign here because queen bee
service Queenie 8 and Vanessa
so the most important part for this game
was 96 it was a sacrifice that I made
without even food is figuring that
figuring out what's going to happen but
it was a it was a very educated Jeff and
I knew that at least I had enough
compensation but it was a very decision
but I think I couldn't live with myself
if I didn't do the sacrifices it's one
of those moments where you had to do it
because it looks so good so you don't
get those you don't get more Muslims
like that in a real in your career so
you know often so you had to take that
chance to to sacrifice so well very
nicely done definitely his flag is India
but he is a Midwestern boy here Chicago
instructor are your students watching
this probably i hope so i will tell them
to us very cool well you are also kind
of in the same boat is joel banawe who
is who has the required amount three I
am norms but it's all about the rating
tell us about that yeah i got i have
foreign arms so far i've got for him to
the years i think my latest one was last
year however my performance sometimes is
up and down happens to those who don't
practice regularly or coach for living
like Joel does it is hard because when
you lose a game against anyone you lose
as much as you gain or worse sometimes a
lot of players nowadays are underrated
or they don't play as many feel a
tournament because in the United States
not all the tournament's our feet are
rated so sometimes we determine that I
do well in our is not rated at all and
the term that I do badly and its feet
are rated so if there are some
complications but in the end I can only
blame myself not enough practice not
enough not enough putting it around ours
and so if I put those hours in I should
be able to get get the next one I hope
it works out already can join ya and now
let's take a look at some more standings
after a full eight rounds have been
completed in the GM section only one
player left can earn a norm and oddly
enough four and a half points in this
section we'll get abrahamian and IM norm
who are here after round eight of the
2017 winter invitational and in the IM
section we
happy day master Doug Eckert Doug thank
you for taking the time to talk to us
about your game your big win with josh
cohen thank you first I want to
congratulate Jill bana hua who scored
and I am norm and across the 2400 rating
with his win in this round so he is
going to officially become an
international master which is the point
of this tournament and last night I
helped him out and that endeavor I
turned on a draw offer and I lost a game
that was very heartbreaking to him last
night and I'm feeling a lot better today
after last night definitely big news for
Julie yeah so today I played Josh and we
transpose from a ready opening into a
Catalan opening you know and if be four
I've got night to be three and the
computer thinks that White's better
there also but again if you look at this
position right here again very hard for
white to play this because all of a
sudden night f4 is a possible threat and
you'll notice that if rook takes d3e
takes d3 makes bishop on h4 jars my
queen for Queen take these seven is not
going to win here so again practically
black has some chances here what he
played though turned out to be a losing
move he played f3 and his idea is to
undermine the pond the problem with this
is is that it allows me to create just a
monster passed on on e3 and even though
white is up in exchange here all of a
sudden the threats are starting to grow
I've got Bishop F to check I have some
lines right play 96 night f4 and I've
also with this night on this square in
the bishop guarding the queening square
I'm threatening to interpose a piece on
d3 here which is going to win the game
and he didn't see that threat but
already the computer thinks that the
position is too late and it gives the
move that he played king h1 actually is
the best move here but it allows a
winning combination for black so I first
thought I play Bishop to d3 and he has
to take the bishop or otherwise I'm just
going to play Queen takes Knight and
I've want peace
so he plays rook takes Knight takes and
now if he plays Queen takes d3 I just
played a two and then I I going to clean
the pawn or he'll have to sacrifice his
rook Bart and then I'll actually be the
one the exchange up and he still has it
loose King position issues to deal with
here so he plays nights before attacking
the pawn and you know I I sensed that I
was winning here the material is equal
that is king is weak and I was trying to
find a winning plan and you know White's
idea here is he's going to play f4 and
play 95 and I've got to find a way to
rearrange my pieces i'm not going to
check made him here and so I was happy
with the plan I found play first of all
I check him and if King goes to g1 and
now I just guard the pond so he can't
play Knight takes III because of Queen
takes III and work takes 90 losses and
exchange their so the pawn star he plays
f4 with the idea of playing 95 night g6
check so to guard that I played Bishop
f6 and it's also important that by
putting the bishop on the d 4 square
which is what it took me a little while
to find before I played night up to
check is that this is sort of a classic
case where with opposite colored bishops
blacks going to have the advantage
because I totally dominate the black
squares so I'm going to put my bishop on
d4 and as you'll see here in a moment
I'm going to open up his position by
playing g5 so he plays a 4 he doesn't
really have a lot of moves here i put my
bishop on b4 and now my plan is to you
know either maneuver my night to e4 and
some lines or might clean to h4 and
Queen g3 a lot of different
possibilities here so he puts this King
on h2 and now I played g5 at first you
say well that opens up my king position
but it doesn't really because I've got
complete control of black squares and if
he plays a move like F Phi for example
now I can just play Queen check this
King has to come back to g1 I can play
Queen to g3 and you can see it's
completely over i'm going to play Knight
takes h3 check if King goes back night
check night takes g4 and its mate
so he cannot move the pond so he puts
his clean up on f3 to guard the pond but
now what I do is he's pin so i played
Queen c7 so the F bonus pin now and he
doesn't really have a good plan to stop
Queen takes f4 so he made me give up my
black squared Bishop here but it's
really a pretty easy win at this point
so he has to come back here and now I
played night the d3 so I'm hitting the
queen square at the night and just
threatening e2 and I was happy with this
because it was a clean win on my part on
like last night where I blundered so he
brings his Queen here f2 Brooke here
Queen scheck King h 2 93 and he resigned
here and I'm going to win the rook but
just to show that it is a win for
example he played Queen to see three I
can simply interpose the rook on this
square and he has no checks and I'm
simply going to win the work on e 1 for
a pawn alternatively in this position if
he brings us Queen down to f7 with the
idea being that if I take his rook that
you know he might be able to get a
perpetual check I very simply just play
Queen to f4 check here and he has to
trade Queens and then I'm going to win
his rook and I win the game so I was
happy with that it was double edged I
was maybe losing at one point but
practically it was very difficult for
him well congratulations on that dog a
fine win indeed now you're a local man
you're also on the board of directors
here at chess club which finds you as a
regular in these types of events still
no I am norms though yet as you're at
the feed a master position what is your
forecast on getting one of those norms
one of these days well you know on this
tournament had a number of very good
positions and I haven't finished them
and this has been my struggle the last
couple years I generate promising
positions and mostly players are rated
200 points higher than me and I haven't
finished and I don't know if it's a case
of nerves lose
concentration in a critical position and
I have to get over that and if i do then
i would probably eventually get a norm
if I don't then I guess I'm just the
player that I've always been which is
I'm okay but not good enough and well
you're not a professional chess player I
mean you have a real life job so to
speak I do but I enjoy this and this is
my passion of my hobby and I like the
ability to compete against these guys
there's a lot of great young
up-and-coming players and I mean if you
look at this tournament even Joshua beat
who's not having a good tournament he
keeps score to Grand Master norm in the
last year which is a level above the
international master level so all of
these players are capable of beating
anyone else in the tournament even me
and I just enjoy that I like competing
and it's a lot of fun it's frustrating
sometimes but I enjoy it now people who
have been following this tournament know
that today and tomorrow the penultimate
and the final round there's only our
days there's only one round each day
which is a little bit different from
what's been the past few except for you
Doug because your first round game will
be played later tonight explain that
well I was out of town on a business
trip and I was actually also playing the
Southwest open in Dallas and
unfortunately one of the participants
dropped out of the GM norm and in these
types of tournaments you need to have
players of a certain rating in order to
meet the either Grandmaster IM
qualifications and they weren't able to
find another player so I agreed to play
on one day's notice but I was out of
town and I couldn't make the first round
who I had to return for my business trip
yeah unfortunately we're talking about
90 mikey j who was sick prior to the
start of this round so she does not
acquire this event so Doug I hope you're
not tired and good luck in the game
greater tonight but you're both for
being here and now we're going to fast
forward through time after eight rounds
plus the games later tonight and show
you the full standings in the IM section
after round eight by now in the IM
section only two players can earn
norm an astounding six and a half points
in this section will net banawe and
william and IM norm the final round goes
down on tuesday februari 21st here from
st. Louis and you can see the games live
on us chest champs calm